gretchen dutschke auf den spuren der
revolte bei jeder demo war sie damals
mit dabei die austauschstudentin aus den
usa die sich in den studentenführer rudi
dutschke verguckte und er sich in sie
hochzeit inklusive seine stimme war die
stimme des protests revolution ist ein
lange komplizierter prozess wo der
mensch anders werden muss
nichts weniger als sich und die welt
verändern wollten sie damals anders
leben anders lieben frei friedlich
solidarisch vor der technischen
universität in berlin trifft gretchen
dutschke auf die studentenproteste von
beute
ok
die zeiten haben sich geändert um geld
geht es nicht so sehr um politik das
aber am anfang auch nichts gab natürlich
andere faktoren aus vietnam krieg hatten
sie ein großes spiel
es waren die großen themen für die sie
vor 50 jahren kämpften
die 68er bewegung hat politik sehr
populär gemacht also dass sich viele
auch damit beschäftigen wollen und das
wieder abgeflaut
also dass die leute irgendwie meine
politik bringt nichts
[Musik]
manchmal kapseln gedacht dass man auf
die richtige seite der geschichte steht
und dass das wirklich was sehr gleichen
wert dass wir was erreichen
wolfgang wieland wollte etwas erreichen
als jurastudent im ersten semester geht
er 1967 zur demonstration vor der
deutschen oper
der schah von persien das zu besuch
die studenten protestieren gegen seinen
unrechts regime die berliner polizei
schlägt auf sie ein
er schießt sogar einen von ihnen wenn du
ohne sorgen
jeder hatte das gefühl benno ohnesorg
das hättest du selber auch sein können
sie haben uns hier grundlos
zusammengeprügelt es waren ja nicht nur
die schüsse eine art gemetzel das hier
stattfand auch die presse macht mobil
gegen die demonstranten
insbesondere die bild -zeitung des
verlegers axel springer
zehn monate später fallen wieder schüsse
ein verwirrter hilfsarbeiter will
studentenführer rudi dutschke tüten der
überlebt schwer verletzt
die leute aufgehetzt haben haben die
leute das einfach geglaubt und ließ sich
auf plätzen
vor dem axel-springer-haus eskaliert der
protest
[Musik]
die regierung verabschiedet die
sogenannten notstandsgesetze kann ab
jetzt die grundrechte einschränken
gut 20 jahre nach der nazi-diktatur ein
schock für die studenten
es war die angst dass die kurze phase
der demokratie in der alten
bundesrepublik schon wieder vorbei ist
doch es kommt anders 1969 der
amtsantritt von willy brandt zum ersten
mal ist ein sozialdemokrat bundeskanzler
und die 68er verändern nicht die welt
aber den alltag kindererziehung arbeit
liebe alles wird offen am liberalen eine
kulturrevolution aber nachhaltig
das war hinterher ein anderer staat als
vorher
gretchen dutzmann rudi stirbt 1979 an
den spätfolgen des attentats
die
heute lebt sie in einem feministischen
wohnprojekt und sie ist mitglied bei den
grünen kämpft dort für eine bessere welt
[Musik]
wenn wir kein geld haben dann haben wir
gar nichts
wolfgang wieland hat den marsch durch
die institutionen angetreten
ende der 70er hat er die berliner grünen
mitgegründet und war später sogar
justizsenator mit dienstwagen und
krawatte
demonstrieren geht er immer noch gegen
rechts denn auch hierzulande sind die
rechtspopulisten auf dem vormarsch die
alternative für deutschland fdp bei der
letzten bundestagswahl auf zwölf prozent
der stimmen
die kfd protestiert in dem sinn gegen
die schwächsten der gesellschaft und sie
macht das mit populistischen themen mit
rassismus mit ausgrenzung mit treten
nach unten unser protestes immer gegen
oben gerichtet gewesen
dies sind 12 prozent wir sind 88 prozent
oder was nicht also die können es uns
nicht wegnehmen
direkt vor dem axel springer haus dem
sitz der bild zeitung ist inzwischen
eine straße nach rudi dutschke benannt
die 68er sind offensichtlich angekommen
in einem land das sie einst bekämpften
dann veränderten und nun gegen rechts
verteidigen
der kampf geht weiter
[Musik]